[Música]
hablamos de revista de prensa con rosa
pérez más de euros a bienvenida a feliz
jueves para ti muy buenos días vamos a
empezar a hablar con un caso que tocamos
aquí en nuestro programa directo américa
el de marta sepúlveda vamos a comenzar
con el país de américa un juez de
colombia por fin ordenó que se permita
la eutanasia a esta mujer buenos días
raúl exacto con esto abre la edición
americana del país vamos a recordar
porque aquí en colombia este caso ha
sido muy mediático y conocido pero no sé
hasta qué punto nuestra audiencia de
otros lugares lo tenga presente marta
sepúlveda es una mujer de 51 años que
padece ela una enfermedad degenerativa y
que el pasado 10 de octubre se iba a
convertir en la primera persona
colombiana en poder someterse a atenas
ya sin padecer una situación terminal
sin embargo poco antes de que se
realizara el procedimiento la clínica
que lo iba a hacer se echó para atrás
marta sepúlveda llevó el caso a los
tribunales y ayer el juzgado número 20
de medellín fallo a favor de sepúlveda y
él dijo que la clínica había vulnerado
su derecho a morir dignamente
por lo tanto este centro médico a
establecer en un plazo de 48 horas una
nueva fecha y una nueva hora de acuerdo
con sepúlveda para reanudar el
procedimiento vamos a ver entonces qué
pasa con este caso rózsa pero ahora
tocamos otro tema uno que hemos venido
hablando nuestros noticieros hablamos
del praxis de la disputa entre francia y
reino unido- empezamos con de guardia en
francia usa lenguaje de fuerza las
discusiones sobre el derecho a la pesca
post brasil exacto esta hemos querido
empezar por este punto de vista
británico porque the gardian a lo que
argumenta es que este es el punto más
crítico de las relaciones entre londres
y parís en mucho tiempo y señala que
como el elíseo está intentando que la
respuesta a este asunto sea global de la
unión europea está pues esta
problemática puede afectar a otros a
campos de discusión abiertos entre
londres y bruselas como es el protocolo
de irlanda no y la ubicación de estas
aduanas entre reino unido y la unión
europeo y la unión europea en este
escenario pues brics y así es rosa vamos
a ver ahora el punto de vista francés
con el diario le monde por brásil
primera se represalia de francia contra
el reino unido- exacto es que medio
francés lo que recoge son las
declaraciones del posicionamiento del
gobierno de francia que asegura que no
se trata de una guerra sino de un
combate pero respondiendo a lo que
señalaba the gardian que ninguna ningún
tema que requiera de la cooperación
entre la unión europea y el reino unido-
va a prosperar hasta que no se resuelva
primero este asunto deja así rosa tenía
algo no tumba vamos a ver vamos a ver a
ver qué pasa en todo exacto pica y se
extiende como dirían rosa pero ahora sí
vamos a hablar entonces de la cob 26 que
inicia este domingo en glasgow en
escocia nosotros vamos a tener un
cubrimiento especial con nuestra enviada
especial la marina a colorado rosa pero
también en el marco está con 26 hay una
conferencia paralela y es de los jóvenes
contra la crisis climática llamada la
coidh 16 porque ya son 16 años seguidos
lo que hacen esta cumbre cierto rosa
exact y esta cumbre de los jóvenes
empieza precisamente hoy y recordemos
que en septiembre hubo unos encuentros
previos también dejo en el que grita
samberg lleno los titulares
internacionales con su discurso en que
reprochaba a los líderes mundiales que
sus promesas eran vacías no este bla bla
bla que pues sea lleno titulares de
alrededor del mundo pero pues vamos a
centrarnos en esta cop que será
determinante tal y como enseña la este
artículo me encanta como lo dice the
economist cop out además ya ha hecho
seguimiento con unos artículos muy
interesantes sobre esta con 26 excepto y
es que cop out es un juego de palabras
porque en inglés cop out significa y
desentenderse lavarse las manos de algo
y entonces lo que defiende es que este
artículo de the economist es que por un
lado puede ser decepcionante esta cumbre
climática porque desde
1995 se suceden no las cops y al final
de cada cop hay acuerdos protocolos
compromisos sin embargo continúa
aumentando la temperatura global y el
cambio climático es ya una realidad pero
también defiende por otro lado que pues
a las cops son el instrumento más
valioso que tenemos como humanidad para
hacer frente dice a una que es que es
más de siete mil millones de personas no
pueden convivir y vivir bien en el
planeta si no dejamos de lado los
combustibles fósiles y si te parece te
leo la conclusión de este articulo raúl
que dice la crisis climática se debe a
un cambio que está fuera de control si
respondemos a ello el mundo puede
convertirse en un lugar donde la
prosperidad a largo plazo sea posible
para todos un futuro noble que la época
de los combustibles fósiles a pesar de
su abundancia ilusoria nunca podría
haber creado y no hay que dejar a un
lado ros a la imagen no ciego sordomudo
refiriéndose a los líderes de la cob 26
y los pingüinos pues en un pedazo de
hielo chiquito diciendo que se está
derritiendo el hielo y ya no tiene
espacio para vivir rosa muchísimas
gracias nos vemos mañana viernes con más
de revista de prensa precisamente vamos
a continuar hablando de este tema una de
las consecuencias de la crisis climática
con este primer invitado del día le
parece
[Música]